foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
is that Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
it's Monday morning
[Music]
this mother woker
I've been wondering
this morning as I've been reading
um Elon Musk [ __ ] tweets
about what is wokeness what is being
Luke
I haven't figured it out
in 2020
a police officer named Derek shovin
murdered George Floyd with his knee
Stripped Away all his his Humanity right
in front of a crowd of people
for the world to see because they had
their cell phone camera
I thought that's what it meant
like I thought that was the woke
as if
we shouldn't have already known
that police officers in this country and
not all of them but God damn bit of a
majority absolutely do not see Humanity
and black people but black men in
particular
we watched it right on film right on
camera we watched him
sucked a life out of George Floyd
and a lot of people went whoa whoa whoa
I thought that was just
something
that black people complain about I
didn't know that was real
and I thought that was wokeness I I
don't know I'm not really sure
what woke means anymore
I actually think they meet they think it
means you know it's it's a it's another
term for libtard right
if we want to talk about language
this morning he's saying Branch
covidians see it's all it's all these
things that they want to whine and
complain about
they're the snowflakes
okay this is not [ __ ] hard to
understand Elon Musk
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I live in a rural part of the country
there's not one [ __ ] not one
[ __ ] wearing a mask not one
and it ain't just my area where no one's
wearing masks and they should not just
for covid for the [ __ ] flu and
everything else that's going around you
people really you people you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] who
absolutely this is Elon Musk he is
supposed to be the guy who invented
electric cars and believe in science and
[ __ ] he is his goal is to live on
[ __ ] Mars and science is what will
deliver him
to Mars hopefully hopefully he will get
on his cockroach it and go to Mars and
[ __ ] stay there to be quite honest I
couldn't [ __ ] I couldn't wait for a
better [ __ ] day than that piece of
scum to leave this [ __ ] planet [ __ ]
him
why why in the [ __ ] why in the [ __ ] did
Dave Chappelle
invite the richest man on the war in the
world on his [ __ ] stage
and say cheer for him [ __ ] you Dave
Chappelle [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] listen I was so
[ __ ] disappointed by that [ __ ]
clip that Dave Chappelle the loud that
[ __ ] to come up on stage as if
he's some kind of [ __ ] hero
comedians do not see [ __ ]
billionaires and people who put their
foot on the the majority of society
with their [ __ ] power of riches that
was given to them by [ __ ] diamond
mines with their white [ __ ] dead in
apartheid you [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
now the crowd's reaction was completely
correct even even Dave Chappelle's fans
were like [ __ ] this goddamn son of a
[ __ ]
and booed the [ __ ] out of him
frankly if we taxed Elon Musk musk as
much as we boo him maybe he would be put
in his [ __ ] place
it's enough of this [ __ ]
hero
rich people [ __ ] rich people are not
[ __ ] Heroes you dummies
Warren Buffett was the richest man in
the world
you want to hear about you want to hear
about a person who has a shitload of
wealth
who knows what wealth means
that amount of wealth means
that amount of wealth means that you're
a pile of [ __ ] garbage
that's what it means and Warren Buffett
gave away almost his entire [ __ ]
wealth to charity
Bill and Melinda Gates have spent the
last part of their lives the last
[ __ ] 15 years trying to give away all
the money they made
it appears that Jeff Bezos and I hope to
God he does this
tries for the rest of his life to give
away every single [ __ ] cent he has
and if they aren't doing that then
you're [ __ ] garbage you're [ __ ]
garbage to spend 44 billion dollars on a
social media company so that you can
[ __ ] so that you can [ __ ] tweet
thin veiled threats
to one of the top top scientists in our
country
that that didn't go [ __ ] work and try
to make gazillions of dollars no he did
not he worked for the government
Republican and Democratic
Administrations
to try to protect Americans from viruses
you stupid bastards and was he wrong
sometimes of course he was when the [ __ ]
did you wake up and never be wrong Elon
Musk you dumb [ __ ]
but this wokeness stuff has got me
[ __ ] pissed this morning just pissed
off
we are not the one listen they lit Elon
Musk and these [ __ ] alt-right [ __ ]
little in-cell piece of [ __ ] sipping
[ __ ] are saying wake up wake up
but we're the ones who are [ __ ] woke
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
nonsense
I'm so sick and tired of you [ __ ]
little [ __ ] saying that that Liberals
are weak and woke and all this nonsense
all this [ __ ] that is such horseshit
that is not how it is at all liberalism
is not [ __ ] weak you dummies
what do you think delivered as victory
in the Second World War
liberalism delivered us one of the best
Economic Times in this country's history
matter of fact it delivered all your
white privilege to you you dumb
[ __ ] every single bit of it all
the way down to your [ __ ] mortgage
and where you live liberalism delivered
you your white your white [ __ ]
privilege you dumb sons of [ __ ]
I'm so sick and tired of these these
[ __ ] alt-right fascists
absolutely ignoring the [ __ ] truth
and they're the ones who that who are
the [ __ ] true Seekers get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ]
yeah I'm pissed off this morning and
it's better to be pissed off than pissed
on baby
go ask Donald Trump
but this wokeness [ __ ] and this branch
covidian and all this this [ __ ]
garbage that somehow somehow Liberals
are [ __ ] weak
is [ __ ] stupid listen if you go look
at the coven numbers of the number of
deaths
in Liberal blue areas
where they just I don't know do policy
it's not [ __ ] complicated it's not
it's not rocket science
to [ __ ] to [ __ ] set policy in
place I understand that Elon Musk
doesn't understand a goddamn thing about
policy it is clear on that he's
absolutely destroyed Twitter because he
doesn't understand policy he has no
[ __ ] understanding of organization or
governing no [ __ ] clue not even
management just simple management he is
such a dumb [ __ ] I am so [ __ ]
surprised that he hasn't done what
Donald Trump did with his dad's [ __ ]
fortune
I'm absolutely yeah that that's the
reason why Donald Trump doesn't want us
to have his tax returns ain't got
nothing to do with crime [ __ ]
don't care about you knowing if he's a
criminal or not he doesn't give a [ __ ]
he says it out loud he doesn't want you
to know that he's [ __ ] broke because
Donald Trump is broke
he's [ __ ] broke as a joke listen real
[ __ ] billionaires don't beg they're
supporters for five and ten dollars
because they gotta fight their legal
battles
billionaires just pay for their [ __ ]
lawyers
Donald Trump is [ __ ] broke and Elon
Musk is going broke and the reason why
is because they're they're [ __ ]
deluded by Q Anon okay that's what this
is this Elon Musk tirade this weekend
about fauci and branch covidians and
wokeness and all this nonsense it's Q
Anon
it's the internet delusion The Cult
that's what it is it has leaked into his
tiny little brain and he can't help but
blame everyone else for his stupid
[ __ ] problems dude just go be rich
just do that
you you've lived you've lived a great
life so far just go be rich somewhere
[ __ ] you know like I said get on your
cockroach at your dildo machine and go
to Mars already just do it no one's
gonna stop you no one is gonna stop you
from going
and creating your own little habitat on
Mars frankly if you take a few of these
alt-right stupid bastards with you we
wouldn't [ __ ] say a goddamn thing
but here we are here we are have to talk
about wokeness again again
Jesus [ __ ] Christ
they're literally saying literally this
is what they're saying
all over the Internet because Elon
tweeted something about fauci and his
pronouns oh I'm gonna get into pronouns
too no [ __ ] we're gonna have a great day
today Gabe Sanchez had his uh his covet
speaking of Branch covidians uh Gabe
Sanchez had his covid vaccine I don't
mean to out him but here's the thing
he's not feeling well this morning
so so great he's but he's not going to
um I don't know if he gets covered it'll
be a lot less
worry for him
because he got his latest booster yeah I
outed you sorry
but it's just gonna be me today baby I
think I mean unless he starts feeling
better
but he said he he woke up in the
not feeling great
I don't give a [ __ ] I'm here you're here
it's Monday
as we do every single weekday so it's
just me today it's just me yelling into
the microphone folks
so we got plenty of time talking about
pronouns we got plenty of time to talk
about Marjorie Taylor Green Oh baby do
we have a bunch of Marjorie Taylor green
clips
because she's doing the same [ __ ]
thing elon's doing these people are
running out of steam
they're running out of it what [ __ ]
ideas do they have I'm telling you this
Twitter files thing
they they did they did what Donald Trump
did to the Republican Party Elon Musk
has done to the [ __ ] alt-right on the
internet in a matter of weeks just
they're a laughing stock it's a laughing
it's it's a [ __ ] lamp Fest people are
[ __ ] ridiculous
you say that well ER it's the left it
wants to cancel everybody
the left the left wants to cancel people
and they get special treatment when we
find out literally we find out
that it's right-wing accounts that we're
getting special treatment at Twitter
special [ __ ] treatment they had they
had a committee a [ __ ] committee that
oversaw their accounts do you [ __ ]
have a committee overseeing your
accounts at Twitter you woke
[ __ ] no no and the reason why
is because no one is concerned about
liberals
inciting violence
because it doesn't exist no one is
concerned about liberals trying to
overthrow the government our overthrow
democracy around the world because it
doesn't exist it's not liberalism at the
heart of it you stupid [ __ ]
liberalism means freedom you dumb
bastards
and it is really [ __ ] unique and
amazing to see that the right wing is
against wokism but they want us to wake
up to see their dumb delusion
really it's really [ __ ] something
special to see we live in such a time
here I tell you we are at the
intersection of WrestleMania in real
life all the time
and that is exactly what's going on it's
all a show
and it's a show of their [ __ ] altered
reality and delusion and no one better
to show it off than a guy who spent 44
billion dollars on a social media site
to [ __ ] absolutely destroy
destroy that website's great credibility
absolutely destroy it
within a matter of weeks destroy it
no better display of their [ __ ]
delusion
and their Q Anon altered reality because
that's what this is
that's what this is what why do you
think this guy talks to a cat turd
why
why do you think he's talking to
alt-right [ __ ] letting Nazis
back on Twitter because freedom of
speech it's his freedom of speech he
owns the website it's not theirs you
[ __ ] dummy
you are using your freedom of speech
Elon Musk if you can [ __ ] hear me
from this microphone you are using your
freedom of speech to let people post
whatever the [ __ ] they want on your
website they're not using theirs
you stupid [ __ ]
I I just I I I would I would prefer
I would prefer that we all live in the
same reality
that would be nice
now he got a little dose of it when Dave
Chappelle welcomed him up on stage which
Dave Chappelle should have been up on
stage absolutely tearing apart Elon Musk
that's what he should have been doing
not inviting him up so people can clap
now it backfired he booed him
well let me tell you something the
comedians of history and really Dave
Chappelle himself used to be would be
absolutely [ __ ] just
a laughing stock
that you would aggrandize the richest
man in the world
comedians comedy in general
is supposed to go after power it's
supposed to punch up
that's the whole point
is to point it out
there's a great clip of George Carlin on
on CNN
years ago
and he talks about this Andrew Dice Clay
was making jokes about poor people
maybe I'll bring it up maybe I'll find
it and bring it up here
comedians aren't supposed to punch down
and they're definitely definitely and
and you can [ __ ] yeah oh comedians
can do whatever they want it's their
freedom of speech it is
it is and it's also our freedom to call
it out and I'll call it out
I didn't see the whole clip of Dave
Chappelle maybe did make fun of maybe
didn't make fun of
Elon Musk the whole reason why he was
gonna come up on stage was to say the
Dave Chappelle line I'm rich [ __ ] and
if you remember this is really [ __ ]
gross Dave this is really [ __ ] gross
the I'm rich [ __ ] line was from the
Dave Chappelle Show
you remember this
and the I'm rich [ __ ] line
is from a bit
where black people receive reparations
and of course Dave Chappelle was making
jokes out of it of course because the
idea that black people would receive
reparations in this country in and of
itself
is laughable because
even in today's age of all us woke
[ __ ] ain't gonna happen
great debate to have
we can't we can't we can't even figure
out
we can't even figure out
Who Doctor found she is and what he was
trying to do not during just this
pandemic
against the coronavirus but what he's
done for viruses his entire [ __ ] life
we can't even figure that out
whoosh
we're broken we're absolutely broken
foreign
to defend what we have
and this woke [ __ ] again this wokeness
or or woke virus whatever the [ __ ] he's
calling it woke mind virus I don't know
point is is that they're the ones who
are cancer culture you remember Potato
Head and Eminem Jesus Christ Rhonda
santis was going to punish taxpayers in
Florida
taxpayers in Florida
because he wanted to cancel Disney
because Disney
finally came around and said that don't
say Gabriel that's that's [ __ ] gross
that's wrong
Disney finally came around to that
spitting his face
because they weren't going to allow him
to be a goddamn bigot right out in the
open without them saying anything
and it was really the Disney employees
but they they're the cancer culture
group it's been in their [ __ ] D they
invented it they invented boycotting
based on their religious beliefs
for years Jesus Christ you remember when
when when Colin Kaepernick kneeled they
were they were burning [ __ ] NFL
jerseys and [ __ ]
when when several companies came out
in support
of protesting police brutality on black
people they were gonna they were gonna
get rid of NASCAR [ __ ] NASCAR and
they're gonna burn this and burn that
they burn their Keurigs it's really
stupid [ __ ]
they had a problem with Coca-Cola when
Coca-Cola told Georgia to [ __ ] off
that's why I never participate in a
stupid boycott thing it's really stupid
any of you on the left if you can hear
me and you're a liberal and you're
participating some kind of boycott thing
you're [ __ ] dumb boycotting doesn't
work pointing stuff out
pointing stuff out and making people
make different decisions
because because capitalism is a form of
democracy folks whether you like it or
not
whether you whether you lefties like it
or not capitalism is a form of democracy
it's one of the problems that we have
right now
is that money buys you votes
in in capitalism
that's why it's not a perfect [ __ ]
system and it's not capitalism
definitely is not about equality and
equity
because democracy isn't always that
I believe our system of government can
deliver us that we got to really pay
attention
but capitalism is a form of voting
and carrying on and on and on and and
shaming people about boycotting and all
this nice get the [ __ ] out of here
listen if you don't understand that
there's just handfuls of corporations
that own almost everything you [ __ ]
touch in this country you have not been
paying attention
and yeah should we use our trust busting
laws maybe to help some of that sure
fine but you think you think this
Congress is going to do that [ __ ] no you
think Republicans are gonna do that hell
no they want more corporate fascism
they want more of it they don't want
they don't want more competition they
want less
that's why they that's why they're like
boycott this and boycott that
so when you're saying the word boycott
no know where it derives from
you can point out and and say I I am not
going to I am not going to support this
company so cancel your subscription stop
giving them money that's your vote
understand it that's your vote and you
add the freedom of speech to speak out
against it
but cancer culture is is what the right
does
it's what the crypto fascists do it's
what they've always done
and it's unsuccessful
in this day and age and the reason why
is because corporations really in in all
honesty they give a [ __ ] about one thing
and one thing only they're [ __ ]
bottom line they don't give a [ __ ] about
lgbtq they don't give a [ __ ] about
pronouns they don't give a [ __ ] about
wokeness they don't give a [ __ ] they
know you give a [ __ ]
they know they know if their customer
base gives a [ __ ] then they better
pretend that they give a [ __ ]
that's the reality
what do you think Elon Musk is doing
what do you think he's doing
all the garbage came back to Twitter
and he's got to remain popular because
without his popularity Elon Musk is
nothing
he's nothing without his popularity and
by God he'll pay 44 billion dollars to
have it you better be damn sure of that
he's a goddamn snowflake he's a [ __ ]
punk ass [ __ ] he definitely will pay 44
billion dollars and lose a shitload more
just just to appear popular he don't
give a [ __ ]
just like Trump he definitely definitely
will pretend to be popular
and it's all a scheme to convince us to
be distracted
that's what the hunter Biden thing is in
the house the [ __ ] committee that we're
gonna have and we have to mock them
Rachel bittickoffer you know one of my
favorite political strategy my favorite
political strategist I should say
she said over the weekend she tweeted it
look the best [ __ ] weapon that we can
use in our democracy against this
nonsense just just this vile nonsense is
to mock the ever-loving [ __ ] out of them
that's my version of it
but we have to mock them
and we have to continue we can't leave
Twitter
you leave Twitter that's what he wants
like literally if you leave Twitter and
you don't [ __ ] with him that's what he
wants he does not want to be [ __ ] with
so mock them
at every turn because it really is dumb
it really is dumb that they're saying oh
look
the branch covidians
have woke my the woke mind virus they
need to wake up
and realize the truth we need to wait so
we're woke but we need to wake up it
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
whatsoever it's not supposed to it's a q
Anon World we're just living in it baby
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] it's weird stuff but
what do you expect
what do you expect from the former
richest person in the world who gained
his who gained his fortune from
apartheid from his rich white privilege
of apartheid what do you what do you
expect from this [ __ ] huh
yeah
and shame on you Dave Chappelle I you
know a lot of people have a lot of
different reasons why to hate Dave
Chappelle
but this this yeah God damn you gross
[ __ ] you are a gross son of a
[ __ ] I want to hear Dave Chappelle talk
about why the [ __ ] he did this now maybe
he did it because he knew this the crowd
in San Francisco would absolutely
[ __ ] boo Elon but I doubt that's the
case I doubt it I doubt it
doubt me everyone this is Monday it is
the very beginning of a week it's gonna
be a big week it's gonna be a big week
of news it always is and I don't know
what to tell you
I I just come here to commentate on what
happens I I don't get to decide what
happens I just tell you how I feel about
it and how maybe you're supposed to go
out into the world and feel about it and
I take my advice you can't and [ __ ] you
it doesn't matter to me come here watch
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch
simulcasting from the minus touch
Facebook page make sure to follow us on
Facebook or me US me at the Tony
Michaels that's where we're at on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels on
Facebook we're almost at a thousand whoo
baby we got a thousand a thousand
followers over on Facebook over on the
book's face I don't know is that good I
don't [ __ ] I don't know I don't know I
keep losing Twitter followers but follow
us there at Tony Michael's pod
um I keep blocking people not blocking
but I I soft block them you know what
that is where someone Falls she's like I
don't want this [ __ ] to follow
me so I I block them and then unblock
them and it's soft follow it it makes
them unfollow you
uh someone was saying the other day that
I lost a bunch of followers and it's
because I keep soft blocking people
if you're a right-winger Elon stamp or
anything like that I don't want you
following me you come watch and all that
[ __ ] hey just stay off my [ __ ] would you
go follow and go follow the Pod page at
Tony Michael's pod my personal account
get the [ __ ] out of here I I care less
how many people follow me but I do care
I do care if you subscribe to YouTube
that is very important you must
subscribe to YouTube we're over 12 000
Subs now we should try to get to 20.
should we have a big [ __ ] campaign to
try to see if we can get the 20 000 Subs
I don't know maybe we could do that at
the beginning of the year maybe that's
our New Year's resolution get to 20 000
subscribers on on YouTube see how fast
we can do it
see how fast we can get the 20 000
subscribers so subscribe there also
download every single episode of the
Tony Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify
Google
make sure you leave a review while
you're subbing there
whatever your favorite directory is
and you are the best audience in the
world and I say in the world because we
get viewers all around the world they're
listening live right now they're in the
YouTube chat right now all around the
world
forget the time it's it's noon Eastern
11 Central 9 Pacific here in the States
but people all around the world are
listening right now as we speak
and I'm going to give you a little tip
Christmas is coming go to
store.thetonymichaels.com use the promo
code podcast use the promo code podcast
at
store.vtonymichaels.com get you 10 off
your entire purchase the entire thing
Christmas is coming
get your the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty or
maybe maybe just maybe around DeSantis
can go [ __ ] himself coffee mug t-shirt
you know whatever you want or doubt me
merch you can get you some doubt me
merch over there
go to
store.dtonymichaels.com that's
store.thetonymichaels.com show your
support for the show we appreciate all
of you being here this week
to start to a great week everyone stick
around
I'll be right back all right after these
messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
well it was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam jams skull
near run out Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
I come [ __ ] a [ __ ] a [ __ ] em [ __ ] up
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
oh what a throwback
trucker Convoy doesn't that feel like
what is going on on Twitter right now
some sort of trucker Convoy she needs a
[ __ ] crazy
murdered
that one
yeah what a weekend having them
read read Elon Musk Twitter feed really
[ __ ] dumb and then watch all these
Marjorie Taylor green videos it's the
same [ __ ] it's the exact it's the exact
same [ __ ] it's all queuing on I'm
telling you
I'm telling you it's all Q Anon and it's
projection that's what the woke mind
virus is remember remember
um uh oh it was sad I don't know it was
last year
last year
maybe it's 20 21 [ __ ] I don't know hey
last year was 2021 we're getting so
close to 20. I don't even know what time
I don't know what year it is I'm so
[ __ ] confused by what wokeness is but
you remember this Mass
uh Mass psychosis do you remember this
[ __ ] they really tried to push that
like that was a thing they wanted they
had the CRT thing and then you know
critical race Theory which was [ __ ]
all [ __ ] we all knew it was [ __ ]
they knew it was [ __ ] and then they
want they wanted to flip the mass
psychosis on us it's Mass psychosis it
was the it was the whole getting the
vaccine and and wearing a mask you know
to prevent uh deadly virus and prevent
from spreading a virus
that sort of thing that was killing
thousands of people thousands of
Americans needlessly
man especially at that point because we
knew
we knew what the science was at that
point especially with the [ __ ]
vaccine that this was going to prevent
deaths
and we didn't know the full we didn't
know the full facts behind the vaccine
because we hadn't done it yet
and we hadn't done it on a mass scale
but as the mass scale started to take
the vaccine everyone realized the
[ __ ] science and the truth the data
came in and you just there was less
death with the vaccine less death with
the vaccine that's just the way it was
there was less sickness there was no
there was not as many hospitalizations
it just it was just [ __ ] data you
dummies
and they're still losing their minds
over mandates that do not exist
it's like the [ __ ] military mandate
you're yeah yeah
this is the one that gets me the best
because that's really the only [ __ ]
mandate that really still exists is if
you join the military right now you're
gonna have to get a coveted vaccine like
I'm not joining and they're like oh this
is affecting this is affecting military
recruitment good why in the [ __ ] listen
I I am not I was never in the military
I wasn't in the military I have family
members that were in the military I have
friends that were in the military I have
people who I associate with on the
interwebs that were in the military have
family spouse loved one in the military
they will tell you
when you go to the military
you go get dozens of vaccines and you do
not not have a choice they don't give a
[ __ ] you are going to get these vaccines
you are now in a contract with the
government of the United States and DOD
you're getting vaccines that is how it
works dummy
that's how it's always worked Jesus
Christ we've used we've used the men and
women of the military to experiment on
with vaccines
they've always mandated vaccines it's
not [ __ ] new and really honestly
to me
if you're going to join the military and
you're like nope not going to do it
because of a because of a coveted
mandate vaccine good
stay the [ __ ] away from our military
honestly that
stay the [ __ ] away from it go go do your
thing in the private sector
go do your thing in the private sector
honestly [ __ ] if you're if you're dumb
enough to not understand why the
military has vaccine mandates in the
first place let alone the coveted one
fine you do you are not you were you are
not fit to be in our military as far as
I'm concerned [ __ ] you
I'm fine with that I'm fine with that
military is a whole another class of
contracts and we do not need to have
people in the military
who were not willing to take orders
that's just not a thing that's like the
whole it's like the whole [ __ ] point
right
whoosh
whoosh
but they're so hyper focused on on on
[ __ ] that doesn't even exist
the reason why there's no pandemic
because there is no pandemic folks
there's no pandemic is there is there a
reason to worry about viruses to worry
about sickness absolutely just as there
is every [ __ ] day of the week
anywhere and we're never going to get
away from that
what what do you what do you think we're
just going to give up on all science and
all [ __ ] [ __ ] and just let viruses
influenza and everything else just to
run rampant you people are dumb
it's a stupid [ __ ] thing to think
that we're not gonna work hard as a
country to try to make sure that that
the majority of our country is at least
at least aware of viruses
Jesus Christ how how long have we had
the flu vaccine every year
now I know that there's a small
population of people who have always
been anti-backs which most of them have
been hippie type liberals
lefties
not [ __ ] alt-right morons
this Q Anon stuff like I said that's all
this is is Q Anon stuff is special right
it's really there's Q anons This Nazi Q
Anon stuff because that's what it is
folks
it's right-wing Nazism this Q Anon stuff
you don't believe me go look at where
this shit's coming from go look at who's
disseminating this nonsense this just
dribble it's the right wing
it's the America First Nazi party
why do you think why do you think the
best of the best of the Nazis are the
ones repeating this stuff why do you
think why do you think Elon Musk has to
placate the Q Anon
on his new 44 billion dollar [ __ ]
trash fire Twitter
because there's a bunch of Nazis on
there
he's like yeah Nazis are welcome come on
in and they crowded in on Twitter now
he's like well I gotta
I got a placate to the Nazis now and
it's all queuing on stuff again and you
you can go talk to a bunch of q a
experts Cults experts all this stuff
what do you think what do you think Mass
psychosis is
how do you think how do you think in the
1930s and 1940s in Germany
Hitler is able to convince people
of fascism Mass psychosis
that's how it's a mass psychosis
now they want to [ __ ] project their
Mass psychosis onto us as if wokism is
some kind of [ __ ] mindset or some
[ __ ] look it's just common human decency
you dumb [ __ ] if if someone
wants to be referred to him he him or
she her they that whatever the [ __ ] just
common decency look you have a [ __ ]
name right I could call Elon Musk a
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] and never call him
anything but a dumb [ __ ] he could ask me
to my face please don't call me a dumb
[ __ ] I want to be referred to as Elon
what do you think when people are like
hey look I don't want to be referred to
as she her are they them it's the same
it's just words why why is the right so
[ __ ] scared of words why are you
right-wing snowflakes so [ __ ] scared
of words you were such [ __ ] punk ass
[ __ ]
and I'm sick and tired of you projecting
your weakness on the Liberals I'm
[ __ ] tired of it I am sick and and
I'm sick and tired of liberals playing
that stupid [ __ ] game
look if you want to be referred to as
she her he him them they fine great that
is your preference that is your Liberty
to that be your preference but when
someone comes after you [ __ ] them if
they if they miss gender you or whatever
[ __ ] them that is a them problem not a
you problem
it's not we do not have to be [ __ ]
weak in this time we do not have to be
weak and we do not have to stand back
and watch these [ __ ] try to
project their weakness onto us we do not
have to do that we don't
who get honestly if someone doesn't have
the common decency if someone doesn't
have the common decency to refer to you
the way that you want then it's a them
problem and you just and by them using
their Liberty of freedom of speech we
now know they're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
right
we know they're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
because that's that's what this is
they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
and they're trying to project their
weakness onto US
imagine imagine
being in a room with someone
and they and you refer to them as the
wrong imagine walking up
to Nick Fuentes or Matt Walsh or Ben
Shapiro or Elon Musk are Donald Trump
and referring to them as a woman
imagine
just imagine
if you referred to Matt Walsh as her
are they oh my God they would lose their
[ __ ] minds
they would lose their [ __ ] minds
that's they're projecting their weakness
on us I've never I've never watched
someone ever in my life
lose their minds in front of someone
because they they used a pronoun that
was not preferable to them
most decent people would be like look if
you're gonna call me by name this is
what I want you to call me and the other
decent person's like yeah that's cool
they're words
they're words
literally pronouns or words and if
you're butt hurt and you're offended
that someone announces their pronouns
or wants to tell you what their pronouns
are that's a you [ __ ] problem man
that is not a them problem
it really it really is a you problem
Elon Musk you got a you problem when it
comes to pronouns
it's a you thing
has to do with you
and when you say and when you say when
you say your pronouns are prosecute and
found she holy [ __ ] you're even showing
your [ __ ] ignorance even more to us
and really really the the point of all
this is that this is the narrative
inside the Republican party because
Elon Musk
bought Twitter
to message
for the Nazis
towards what it is
he's bought Twitter for 44 billion
dollars
to turn Twitter into a messaging machine
for the [ __ ] Nazis now I'm not gonna
let him do it I'm gonna call it out
every single [ __ ] time I don't give a
[ __ ] now on my show I I I just haven't
been tweeting much lately I mean I go
look
and we're going to surf the Tweety
tweets and the trendy Trends here
as long as that [ __ ] still
exists but I'm not leaving Twitter
Hells to the no let me tell you
something
if there was a protest
and a bunch of Nazis showed up to
protest across the street I would not
leave that protest no [ __ ] way it
would only it would only solidify my
resolve in that protest to stay and to
be the voice against the fascist
that came to protest me [ __ ] them
because that's what's happening folks
they're terrified
they're terrified of liberalism they're
terrified of democracy they're terrified
of the majority ideology in this country
they're terrified of it they're
terrified of decency they can't stand it
and the reason why is because they don't
have decency
they don't have empathy
they don't give a [ __ ] about anyone but
themselves
especially when they possess white
privilege
especially when they possess white
privilege
but we can't relent we can't run away
that's not us that's not liberals
liberals aren't weak
antifa anti-fascist no we won World War
II
we brought our we brought
the West the liberal democracy
and democracies into the 21st century
We Can't Stop Now
we can't turn back now
's not the time
Now's the Time to lean into it lean into
liberalism
give it to him a little bit show them
that the liberalism of the past that
delivered White Privilege in this
country after the second world war can
deliver Equity Inequality For All people
not in just this country but around the
world it is a thing that can happen
thank you
I believe it if liberalism can believe
it can deliver if you believe and I
believe that liberalism can deliver such
White Privilege as it did in this after
the second world war in this country
then it can deliver equity and
inequality for every single person in
this country and around the world
I wholeheartedly have a lot of
confidence in those statements
I wouldn't do this every day if I didn't
believe that
I wouldn't sit here and Yammer on and
yell and scream into the microphone
trying to trying to push the narrative
trying to change the narrative that
liberalism is not weak it's the people
bitching about about their projection
onto others
that are the [ __ ] weak ones
if Elon Musk had any strength at all any
if he wasn't such a punk ass [ __ ] do
you think do you think we would be
talking about Hunter Biden's dick pics
and and Jesus Christ lives of tick tock
getting special treatment by the way
that's what they did they got special
treatment on Twitter
and and pronouns and wokeness holy [ __ ]
he's such a weak piece of garbage
but it's their message
you remember Jim Jordan tweeted from the
house Judiciary Committee Elon Trump
Kanye
you don't think they still stand by that
you don't think that's who they that's
who they wanted that's who they want to
have their messaging that's why he
tweeted it
that's why they have a hold of their
messaging
no more clear than now
as we sit here and have to talk about
oh woke mind virus again I don't even
know what woke means I don't even know I
don't even know
I have no clue and they don't either
don't get it twisted they have no
[ __ ] clue
I mean again it's it that when they say
wokeness they're it's just their
weaknesses projected onto us and by us I
mean liberals and by liberals I don't
mean capital l i mean people who believe
in democracy the pro-democracy coalition
because ultimately when you get it down
to Bare Bones rather it's an old liberal
or new liberal the classic definition of
liberal capital L liberal lowercase
liberal
most people who are pro-democracies
somewhere deep inside of them
have that liberal voice speaking to them
because it's about freedom
real Freedom not the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people that's not
Liberty that is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ]
so let's do this let's do because I got
speaking of morons who don't know what
Liberty is
I got a lot of Clips to show you of
merger jader green and I wanna I wanna
show you this clip of Elon Musk getting
booed as much as I'm a little perturbed
that Dave Chappelle did what he did I am
glad that the content of Elon Musk being
booed by thousands in San Francisco
exist so what surfed the Tweety tweets
and trendy Trends let's start the
countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
podcast we've reached a part of the show
where we ran up all the Tweety tweets
and trendy Trends and I told you I was
going to get to this Marjorie Taylor
green stuff Patriot tapes posted a few
of these videos this is some kind of
young Republican gal or some [ __ ] in New
York City
okay first off
let's just go over that there's a young
Republican Club Gala in New York City
you know how they always complain like
ah everyone for
eign
that only liberals live in cities and
[ __ ] it's just not true
there are plenty of America First Nazis
and fascists that live
in cities and urban areas I mean
most most people
um you know appreciate the diversity of
cities and urban areas so they tend to
be a little more liberal
or blue or democrat whatever the [ __ ]
you want to say
but they're still there's still pieces
of garbage that live inside these these
places in our country and not no better
display of this than Marjorie Taylor
green who hates New York City New York
State you remember those commercials
what what are those commercials like a
salsa commercial you remember this salsa
for uh Gabe Sanchez if he's listening
he's probably sweating out the covid
vaccine and shedding it all over the
place I'm just kidding
um but uh salza salza commercials we're
gonna you know where where'd they get it
New York City I don't know
she hates New York City that's the point
I'm trying to make here is Marjorie
Taylor green absolutely hates New York
City yet she goes to New York City
do the New York young Republican Club
Gallup
and uh there's a lot of clips from this
thing but this one
um and we'll show here this one she's
talking about her good friend who also
apparently was at this elitist New York
City event for the young Republicans
because I thought that's what all New
York City was was a bunch of [ __ ]
elitist maybe I'm confused but they were
both there listen to what she says about
her great friend and treasonous partner
Steve Bannon I come to Washington I
swear in on January 3rd I get accused of
being Insurrection tours which I thought
was hilarious
this is my story
then did she just admit that she [ __ ]
her pants or something
I don't know that's what I heard and
she's like I couldn't find the bathroom
True Story I mean if you can't find the
bathroom
where do you go
she's [ __ ] a bucket or something
I I'm these are legitimate questions I
think that we should be asking where in
the [ __ ] on January 3rd was Marjorie
Taylor green taking a [ __ ]
I'm dead serious she just said in front
of the the New York Republican Elites
Elites that that she went and she
couldn't find the bathroom
on January 3rd when she was giving the
Insurrection tours
I don't know maybe I'm out of my [ __ ]
mind
foreign
did she just did she just admit to
organizing I don't maybe her and Steve
Bannon I don't know maybe because you
know it's kind of funny that she says
this because Steve Bannon literally
um in the January 6th select committee
hearings if you remember there was audio
tape of Steve Bannon basically planning
out when Donald Trump lost what the
strategy was for them to commit a coup
he was laying it out
well maybe it's just me
okay
so she is uh admitting that if her and
Steve Bannon would have organized the
Insurrection that they would have won
meaning
they lost okay that's number one
you lost the coup attempt
but she definitely wanted to win the
coup attempt
for sure and even in and and going a
step further than if she would have been
involved in organizing the coup attempt
it definitely would have been successful
it's what she's saying out loud rather
she realizes it or not which I actually
don't think that these people realize
the [ __ ] they're saying they really
don't
they really do not [ __ ] have any kind
of [ __ ] filter
it's all just [ __ ] red-blooded
fascism puking out of their [ __ ] pie
hole
but it gets better listen
ing
they would have been armed they would
have been armed I you know maybe this
goes back to who is the bomber right
because everyone wants to know who is
the [ __ ] hoodie bomber you've seen
this the sweat suit bomber you seen this
you've seen this video
of the the person who planted a bomb
at the DNC
has the gray zip up Hoodie
The Mask sunglasses walking around at
night with gloves sweatpants and what
looks like a very unique pair of tennis
shoes
so unique that probably maybe just
possibly very few people would own shoes
like that
but here she's saying on stage in front
of the Republican Elite in New York the
New York Elites the elites the elites
the elites the elites because
Republicans are the elites Elon Musk is
supposedly the richest person in the
world Donald Trump is supposedly a
billionaire their Elites the Republican
basists are Elites
they are the elites
Jesus
okay
she says she would be armed she would
have been armed so we have to assume
armaments May mean guns it may mean
bombs I don't know I'm just saying it
seems kind of funny
suss a bit
that she wants to bring up arms
and there's someone who had almost the
exact same pair of shoes if not the
exact same pair of shoes the exact exact
pair of shoes planting armaments bombs
in the DC area or January 6th I'm just
saying
and I'm like are you kidding me a bunch
of conservative Second Amendment
supporters went in the capital without
guns and they
said
I don't think so okay so here she is
saying again okay okay all right this is
the whole [ __ ] personality conflict
with Marjorie Taylor green all right and
when you're talking to anyone who likes
this [ __ ] scumbag or who who do
[ __ ]
re-fucking copy and paste anything this
scumbag says speaking of copy and paste
real quick we end a ban
um fake gate from Facebook so we're not
gonna have a Cabe anymore so I don't
know if we'll have a new fake copy or a
trump copy machine or Marjorie Taylor
green Gabby machine I hope so I hope so
and we really want to make sure we that
we get someone we can put them in their
place let me show you guys how to do
this now here's what you do
because Marjorie Taylor green is
literally standing on stage saying that
the people at the Capitol were not
conservatives they were not Republicans
and they didn't organize it they as as
in the the America First Nazi party okay
there's she is saying that they were not
Trump supporters yet yet she continues
to Yammer on and on she even made a deal
with Kevin McCarthy to make him speaker
because she wants the people who went
and committed violence at the January 6
Insurrection that was trying to
overthrow our government at the behest
of Donald Trump to make him dictator and
King I always refer to it as the Cheeto
dust kangaroo coup
she wants to make sure
to have those political prisoners as she
puts it released
so which is it Marge
is it a bunch of [ __ ]
non-conservatives non-republicans who
went to overthrow the government and
that were unsuccessful because they
didn't have bombs and and rifles or are
they political prisoners which is it
these people's personalities are so
contradicting
it's so easy to mock them
that's what you should do
that's what we should keep doing because
a lot of people see this clip as
Irrelevant in our political body it is
absolutely relevant
they really they really think two things
at once and the reason why is because
they gotta rile up their Q Anon crowd
right now you got to remember where
she's at
you gotta remember where she's at she's
at the New York Republican young
Republicans elite club
these are elitist
these are [ __ ] elitists these are not
people that would dress up
and and go [ __ ] in in porta potties and
take showers at Planet Fitness to stand
in line for four hours to listen to Mike
Lindell and Donald Trump dribble they
wouldn't do it they wouldn't go to the
Capitol and and [ __ ] go in with the Q
Anon shaman
and pretend that they love Donald Trump
they wouldn't do that
they want to watch this [ __ ] from afar
so that they can say oh it's antifa look
at all these toothless rednecks that's
what the redneck Trump supporters don't
understand is that the Republican Elites
don't actually like them
Marjorie Taylor green because she's
speaking in front of a bunch of [ __ ]
Elites in New York Republican Elites in
New York
is [ __ ] denigrating the people who
went to the Capitol when she goes and
spikes in front of the in front of a
bunch of redneck toothless [ __ ]
the rule you know people sound like me
it's completely different oh those those
people are political prisoners and we
need to release our brothers and sisters
from the from the political
the political imprisonment that they're
in oh it's so it's so hard they they
have to be in prison because they
committed crime
it depends on who they're talking to and
both groups are duped as [ __ ] oh they're
so easily duped Republicans Republicans
and the American first Nazi party is so
[ __ ] dumb so [ __ ] steeped in their
delusion that they're great and they're
the ones who are greatness
that
that they are so easily duped by this
garbage continue she does it again
launch
yeah we're here the [ __ ] out of here
oh and it's another clip it must be
another clip
that's a lot of them from this New York
Republican elite club thing
that's what it is
again they're Republican Elites
elitist
you think Elon Musk isn't an elitist
yeah [ __ ] out of here of course he is
you don't think Elon Musk is an elitist
let's look up
um some more of this nonsense
come on Marjorie Nazi green is trending
on um
I guess that's the beauty of freedom of
speech Let's see if I can find oh here
we go here's a minute of her talking
um denigrate denigrating the lgbtq
community I don't even know if I've
listened to this but let's listen to how
um
Marjorie Taylor Green is right right on
track with Elon Musk his narrative and
his messaging let's listen let me lay
this out just this past week we had two
critical events with the equality of
Marriage Act and the ndaa okay
let me tell you how hard it is to get
our Republican conference is not the
majority yet to all votes the same way
quality of Marriage Act we had
approximately I think it was like 39
Republicans it was 39 Republicans who
voted for decency
yeah
like literally that's the bar
that we can only get 39 Republicans to
vote for decency
it's not your [ __ ] problem if two
people who were in love want to get
married really it's their problem
I've told you this before
marriage isn't [ __ ] easy and anyone
tells you it is has not been married
before it's like when someone who hasn't
raised kids is raising kids is easy you
have not done it before
I mean Marjorie Taylor green of anyone
should know that the sanctity of
marriage doesn't exist
right
sanctity of marriage does not exist
even a Marjorie Taylor green she's
[ __ ] around with uh oan host Matt
gatz Alex Stein 99 you know the guy who
[ __ ] harassed AOC on the steps
apparently that's a big turn on for
Marjorie Taylor green wants to [ __ ] Alex
Steiner did or something I don't know
that's allegedly
I don't I don't I don't I
I don't come up with this stuff I just
[ __ ] see it and tell you guys about
it but the guy you know you know what
I'm talking about the one who harassed
AOC on the steps Alex 9.99
apparently she [ __ ] that guy
apparently
um any any kind of harassment that you'd
give to OAC is a turn on for Marjorie
Taylor green but she's in the divorce
because of this stuff
and she's gonna tell us she's gonna tell
us
what the sanctity of marriage is and we
have to live by her rules of sanctity
and marriage get the [ __ ] out of here
with this [ __ ] let's let's listen to her
bigotry here I'm sure it's about to
happen I haven't watched this clip but
it's coming I can feel it
but for the equality of Marriage Act
and the ndaa
the ndaa we had myself included 35
Republicans both against the ndaa
but by the way
that's that's to um
if you're unaware that's for the
military but let's keep going I know
it's really hard to get all of us about
for something
extremely difficult because our
Republican conference is like a rainbow
of Republicans it really is you've got
people from all over the country okay I
want to stop there again I am not
listening to this clip yet but she is
showing her true fascism just right out
in the open here when she says that that
the Republican party is a rainbow of
ideas what the [ __ ] do you think the
Democratic party is
Jesus Christ I mean literally literally
uh there are there are moderate moderate
Democrats and even moderate Republicans
that are banding with Democratic
Socialist Bernie Bros to vote for
democracy you don't think I mean God
damn we we killed we killed the Big Bird
bill you remember that bill back better
we killed that because we let a bunch of
[ __ ] we let a bunch of [ __ ] the
leftists of the left of the left kill
that bill they didn't want to vote for
infrastructure you remember all that
inviting and [ __ ] that we went
through
that's her showing her fascism what she
wants is a party that only only
adheres to what they want and what their
principles and what their values are
they do not want freedom inside the
Republican party they do not want
freedom of thought
you have to think only this way and you
have to believe and vote only this way
to be a part of our party
it's what she's saying I mean again it's
her wearing her fascism right out in the
open especially to a bunch of New York
Republican Elites but let's keep going
here
people that have one idea in one area
another idea in another area
and conservative all the way to well I
call up Democrats and I can't I can't
figure out why they call them as
Republicans
see see her fascism right out there to
see
I don't know why anyone else can't see
this [ __ ] I mean I
guess I guess it would be
ridiculous ridiculous of me to assume
that they might be self-aware
really it might be okay let's see here
um this next clip from Patriot takes let
me just go down the [ __ ] line here
with this Marjorie Taylor green stuff
now this next
um you see here Margaret Taylor green at
the New York young Republicans elite
club Gala again
a bunch of [ __ ] Wingers who hate
elitist
s that hate New York elitists are going
and talking to the actual elitist in New
York Jesus Christ
um apparently the quote is Alex Jones
was right oh my God this is only 19
seconds I'm sure it's 19 seconds full
of just nonsense but I'm sure we're
gonna laugh at this let's listen
[Music]
so she she loves that Alex Jones named
his his [ __ ] propaganda company
Infowars apparently I guess that's what
she's saying he's right on I haven't
seen some of these clips I'm dead
serious I haven't seen this yet let's
keep listening see if she has any more
knowledge to drop on us
and we're losing
we are losing
but we don't have to be losing okay it's
totally different they are losing
and they will always lose
do you know why they are going to lose
because they can't stop the truth that's
something that they just can't do they
won't stop the truth
and when people when people listen to
their nonsense and their dribble like
Carrie Lake you remember this [ __ ]
they they absolutely don't believe the
garbage
most of Americans think this Q Anon
stuff is stupid
the majority of the country if they paid
attention over the weekend that Elon
Musk tweeting I mean he's a dumb
[ __ ]
didn't he own that thing shouldn't he be
running the company instead of
tweeting out just Q Anon dribble
they understand it come on they
understand it okay here's an here's
another clip by Patriot takes
um Margaret Taylor green laments and
Republicans don't have power to arrest
their political opponents ow
so all the all the [ __ ] you know
nonsense of Grandpa Poopypants freaking
out on his fraud social platform and all
these people oh my God they're gonna
it's a political Witch Hunt on Donald
Trump
you mean they're projecting all that
stuff oh you wouldn't say let's listen I
I haven't I haven't heard this one by
the way let's just see what she says but
there's other things that we have to do
very important things
we actually have to produce a budget
okay I I want to point out too here for
a second since this is a closer shot of
Marjorie Taylor green at the Republican
elitist Club you notice she's not
wearing you know blue jeans and a
t-shirt and a trucker hat right
you notice that
you notice she's got on a gown and and
pearls and a bracelet got her hair did
I'm not saying that's wrong I'm not
saying that's wrong I'm not I'm not
saying Hell maybe she should do herself
up a little more I'm not whatever what
I'm saying is is again it is different
when they when this scumbag goes and
talks to a bunch of [ __ ] New York
Coastal Republican elitist
in New York City
then when she goes to rule bun [ __ ]
wherever
to talk to to rule white rednecks it's
different and she says different [ __ ]
and and you know most politicians do
this this is politics folks I'm not
saying we shouldn't engage in this you
goddamn right we should engage in this
whatever it takes [ __ ] wind democracy
we should do it I don't give a [ __ ] the
messaging is there we should push the
messaging yes absolutely and like she
said we're winning and the reason why
we're winning is because the truth
matters
but the truth is here that she is a
[ __ ] fraud and a [ __ ] phony I just
wish I just wish the killing honors
whether it's the elitist or the [ __ ]
rednecks would realize that they're
being duped by this [ __ ]
you're being duped by this [ __ ]
it's ridiculous that they don't
understand it
come here and listen to me I'm telling
you even if you're a right winger and
you [ __ ] think Trump's the greatest
thing since sliced bread and you got
stupid [ __ ] tires in your dumb
[ __ ] truck and your stupid [ __ ]
Trump flag come listen I will tell you
the truth she is duping you she doesn't
give a [ __ ] about you she doesn't care
she literally went all the way to New
York City to change her entire message
for the elitist
what do you think it was just for
Prosperity or to get their money you
stupid [ __ ] rednecks Puck your head
out of your [ __ ] asses
all right let's let's let's go with the
stupidity here let's keep going
now the power of the purse strings are
very very powerful
and we have to work together on 222 of
us to get on purpose some things okay so
what she's saying here there is some
truth in it again they always have a
kernel of truth there's a little bit of
tethering to the truth uh to alter
everyone in the room's reality right to
have this delusion and what she's
talking about is Appropriations the
House of Representatives appropriates
funds so what happens in our form of
government is the House of
Representatives says hey here's what we
want you to pay for they pass what you
want you to pay for and then it goes to
the the Senate and maybe back to the
house you know back and forth and then
it's a law the bill becomes a law and
the president signs it into law and then
the Executive Branch the president
United States writes the checks that
they appropriate that's why when people
say the president spending money on this
well yeah but Congress actually spent
that money the president's just paying
the bill and okay it's like it's like
when you go to a certain store right you
know what I'm talking about guys man I
don't know who cares what store it is
you go and you buy something you get the
bill in the mail
and your spouse is like what the hell is
this you're like well I bought some
stuff Jesus Christ how much did you
spend you're like just write the check
would you and your spouse writes the
check and mails it off that's what
happens okay now what she's talking
about is appropriating funds now what
she's missing the point on is when she's
using it and weaponizing it right she's
talking about defunding it which is a
thing that can happen the House of
Representatives and the majority in the
house can weaponize the appropriation of
funds to try to negotiate it is a thing
that can happen the problem is
the problem is is what they want to do
is they want to weaponize the and defund
things that the American people need and
want okay this is the problem that
they're truly going to have by having
the house number one they do not have it
by 222 I don't believe well and even if
they do it doesn't matter
they don't have it by much
and there's certainly a group of
Republicans who are going to want to get
reelected in 2024 that live and and
represent districts in which Biden will
win in 2024. that's right Biden's gonna
run he's going to win those districts
and those Republicans know it and if
they don't know it they're [ __ ]
morons so whatever
but here's the thing by her weaponizing
the appropriation of funds to take away
what the American people want out in the
open mainly by defunding the government
it's only going to say the quiet part
out loud that we don't think you should
have this this this or this American
people we don't give a [ __ ] about you
what on Earth would we as pro-democracy
Coalition give a [ __ ] if they project
that out into the world all it does is
give us great ammunition and we can
politicize the ever loving [ __ ] out of
it if you believe because I I think
they're going to come to a deal Mitch
McConnell has already signed them
that he's going to fund the government
into next summer maybe next fall I don't
know how long they're going to kick the
can down the road but they're going to
kick it down to where it's another fight
in another day and it's probably going
to be the summer fall next year I'm not
sure maybe September right September is
probably when we're gonna see
um the next the next government shutdown
I don't know count on it I don't know
Mark it down it's
December 12th it's 1 20 uh p.m eastern
time Tony Michaels said in September
sometime is our next shutdown there you
go there's my prediction and this [ __ ]
is going to be a part of it
but here's the thing here's the thing
that she's miscalculating and she's not
understanding that the American people
when they see the craziness like Kerry
Lake and they get rid of it they they
see when you're a [ __ ] box and you're
you're making sure to hold the American
people hostage because you don't want to
fund certain little things that you
don't like that the American people
actually want
so go for it Marjorie Taylor green
weaponize it good for you
we don't have the White House we don't
have the Senate
222 okay they don't have the white house
so they lost she's admitting that again
Donald Trump is a loser is what she's
saying they don't have the Senate yes
because you're you listen to a [ __ ]
loser you let the loser [ __ ] pick
your nominees and they [ __ ] lost
that's not even not even you didn't lose
numbers the we gained we gained numbers
in the Senate you
boneheads of Representatives
we can investigate on our committees we
can use subpoena power
we can create a budget an
appropriational bills but let me tell
you what we cannot do
we cannot arrest the people we cannot
prosecute
and we can't put people on Jill you want
to know why that's the job and the role
of the Department of Justice at the FBI
and they are corrupt
they serve the Democrats agenda
and they will not help us one single bed
ah she's really putting a damper on the
hole they're going to uh rest Hunter by
Ninja
Hunter Biden listen if you've never
um you know haven't come to terms with
this this is Marjorie Taylor green
telling the Republican Elites in New
York City listen to me when I tell you
this this is Marjorie Taylor green a
representative from Georgia
who is Irrelevant in the grand scheme of
actual ideas and policy not the
messaging she controls the messaging
telling
Republican Elites in New York City that
Hunter Biden is not going to be
prosecuted that's what she's saying
and it's coming the same day that we see
that there's going to be criminal
referrals
coming from the January 6th select
committee which is a committee in the
house it is something that
I don't know Congress people and
committees can do they can give criminal
referrals now Jesus
okay let's see what other Marjorie
Taylor green Clips do we have
from this elitist meeting well let's see
any other good ones any any ones that
people want to see let's see what's this
one uh the internet is not a safe place
it's not a safe place for anyone and
what's the dildo one didn't she talk
about [ __ ] dildos and butt plugs I
thought I [ __ ] retweeted that one
Let's uh I gotta go find it I gotta go
find the [ __ ] dildo talk we cannot
leave here we're we're almost to the
bottom of the the second hour here we
cannot leave without the dildos and the
butt plugs because this is important
this is important stuff that we're
trying to get through here and it only
shows our mindset more than anything
yeah let's see Marjorie Taylor green
bildo maybe that'll bring it up oh just
trying to search here videos oh maybe I
shouldn't search Marjorie Taylor green
dildos in video man what do you think
that's a little dangerous nope back at
delete delete now let's see maybe
okay I'm gonna show you this so I'm
literally uh here searching let's see if
I can uh Marjorie tether green
and um I'm about to search butt plug
Marjorie Taylor green butt plug that is
where we are at
in this state
of our [ __ ] Nationals Mass psychosis
of these Q Anon idiots
then I have to [ __ ] search to show
you
a sitting United States congressperson
who was re-elected
about their [ __ ] rhetoric on butt
plugs I'm not [ __ ] you this is
[ __ ] real stuff and of course it
doesn't bring one up hey Elon someone
get a hold of eon they are centering he
is censoring the research results for
Marjorie Taylor green butt plug what in
the actual [ __ ] is happening over at
Twitter why in the hell aren't the gates
open for the Marjorie Taylor green butt
plug action I'm just saying I don't know
what I'm this video is her talking about
it it's not her using one take it easy
don't go anywhere I don't want the
audience to dump because they think
they're going to see Marjorie day
they're green with a [ __ ] butt plugin
I'm just saying what what do you want
from me it's just me today it's just me
today so we're doing butt plug stuff
okay
um I gotta find this video does anyone
have the link to this video let's see
let me go to um and find a if they got
it in DMS or someone's sending it to me
I know it exists I know it exists
um but oh yep no I got it here thank you
thank you Margie for um sending me the
the butt plug video she's on top of it
our moderators are on it today they know
Gabe Sanchez is off sick
so our mod everyone give love to the
mods in the in the YouTube chat there
thank you to our moderators okay here's
the butt plug video I told you it
existed and here's Patriot takes has it
um major take says Marjorie Taylor green
at the New York young Republican elitist
Gallup
this is the quote we're gonna watch the
video I promise
maybe a couple times I want to
definitely talk about dildos and butt
plugs today
um by the way by the way you can pick up
a butt plug or a dildo at Target and CVS
nowadays what the [ __ ] is wrong with
that
I I thought we want freedom God damn it
if these people are for such Freedom
shouldn't you have the freedom to go
into a Target and a CVS to get a butt
plug
for crying out loud what in the [ __ ]
okay she continues with the quote I
don't even know how we got here what do
you mean how we got here some somebody
likes when does everyone know what a
butt plug is
I mean I'm not saying I know every
single reason why to use a butt plug but
some people like anal sex right some
people like it some people don't
you know to each its own
but some people use the butt plug to
prepare
the anus
for the sex I'm just saying and that's
how we got here Marjorie Taylor green
and then the dildo thing you don't
understand how we got to a place look
most most women shouldn't be attracted
to men in this country in the first
place in the first place and really
women don't need men anymore we have
enough science that they could they
could have enough [ __ ] sperm
to make sure that Humanity lived for
eternity they don't need men anymore
but
Some people prefer you know
ah the hog a sausage and that's show a
schlong I don't know I'm not a woman so
I don't understand some of these things
but you can see the purpose and the
necessaries of a dildo Marjorie Taylor
green what do you mean how we got here
and then and then she goes on to say
this is the state in which we're living
right now what the [ __ ] is wrong with
dildos and butt plugs by the way I'm
just saying
they're just inanimate objects
these these are not these are not demons
walking around right
[ __ ] out of here well let's let's listen
to it
whoa it just seems like she said that
out of nowhere doesn't it I don't have
the piece of footage for the context but
she just jumped right in to dildos and
butt plugs
doesn't it feel like that
like she's like yes our the state of our
national debt is ridiculous and by the
way we can buy butt plugs and dildos
Target and CVS I went in to get one the
other day I I almost imagine
that when Marjorie Taylor green was with
her tantric sex guru whatever the hell
that was
and definitely a hundred percent with
Alex Stein 99 that she has seen a butt
plug with Alex 999 there is no doubt in
my mind no doubt in my mind that she if
she was anywhere near you know naked and
doing things I don't know what what they
were doing I don't know it's just a
rumor I don't know what do you what do
you want what do you want me to do
I I have to talk about it I'm talking
about Margaret Taylor green she is a
sitting United States congresswoman who
is in charge of messaging for the
Republicans she went what do you want me
to do how am I supposed to prevent this
she went to the the New York City
Republican elitist Gala
what do you want me to do I didn't
invite her there I didn't tell her to
come and spew her her messaging upon
them
I didn't make her the queen of the
America First Nazi party's messaging I
didn't do that
I just have to comment on it because she
is the messenger for the America First
Nazi party
I don't even remember oh I remember I
was going Alex died 99 yeah you remember
the guy again who uh was harassing AOC
on the steps of the capital do you think
he was doing that maybe because
he couldn't get his butt plug out I
don't know I'm just saying I would bet
Margaret Taylor green has seen a butt
plug
and the people that she's been sleeping
with probably absolutely know what a
butt plug is let's listen
thank you
I don't even know how we got here
does she mean they don't know how she
how she got here in talking about this
or how we got in this country that
people know what butt plugs and dildos
are and it really didn't bother most
people because you either either use
butt plugs and dildos or you don't
I guess kind of like it's kind of like
getting married and if you're if you're
in a relationship with someone of the
same gender either either gonna love
someone who's the same gender or you're
gonna love someone a different gender
it's really uh you know it's your own
problem
and her being offended this is really
snowflake step by the way her being
offended that CVS and Target which I
don't even know if they sell dildos and
butt plugs much more power to him you
know in his capitalism it is what it is
at this point it's not like you can't
[ __ ] get a dildo or a butt plug off
Amazon for Grant out loud they sell all
kinds of strap-on sex swings and there's
all kinds of [ __ ] pocket [ __ ] there's
all kinds of great sex toys out there
this is technology for crying out
um but how she doesn't understand that
no one is forcing her to go to CVS and
Target and buy a butt plug no one no one
is forcing you to buy these things not a
God damn person is forcing you to buy
this stuff why are you so concerned if
someone else wants to have a butt plug
why
hey Mary
I apologize
oh so she just realized when she's
talking about anal sex that there might
be people eating their chocolate pudding
[Music]
or maybe maybe it was the sight of
chocolate pudding on the table that
reminded her of anal sex and made her
bring up that oh my God I was in CVS
getting a butt plug the other day I
can't believe they actually sell them in
there I bought three of them I can't
believe they sell them in there I don't
know
again why does anyone give a [ __ ] if CBS
our Target or whoever is selling butt
plugs why are they so concerned about
this why is again they're always so
[ __ ] hyper focused on the stupid [ __ ]
that has nothing to do with them it's a
you problem if you're offended that CVS
and Target is selling butt plugs don't
go in there
for crying out loud just don't go in
there find another store that doesn't
sell butt plugs Marge
okay
let's see um speaking of um butt plugs
uh what else do we have
um
here is the um here's the Tweet let's
see if I can find it
here's the Tweet speaking of butt plugs
here's the tweet from uh Elon Musk
and he's super offended by words by the
way he's got to bring up pronouns ah
pronouns
bio what the [ __ ] do you care
[ __ ] the it's the same stupid [ __ ] about
the butt plugs what the [ __ ] do you care
same [ __ ] about gay marriage what the
[ __ ] do you care about who these people
are marrying into you problem Elon that
the pronoun thing and that you [ __ ]
believing stupid [ __ ] chewing on [ __ ]
about fauci is a you thing it's a you
problem
it's a you thing
not an us thing
it's not
it's a [ __ ] you thing
um let's see if we can find a couple
responses to this
um here is uh Rachel bidagofer my good
friend Rachel bittickoffer you guys love
Rachel
the best political strategist in the
world you know I actually I actually
feel like and Rachel will attest to this
because we talked about this before it's
almost like she's the female me and I'm
the male her but we had two different
directions in life right she went and
studied and got her PhD I [ __ ] around
and I talking scream into a microphone
but we feel like we feel we're such good
friends and we get along so much and I
believe that it is the f word that is
it is the f word that has brought me and
Rachel bit a Gover to be such good
friends and I love Rachel bitcover she's
a good friend of the show maybe we
should have her on this week what do you
guys think we should definitely hammer
on this maybe she could point this out
for us she says this morning about this
about Elon Musk worried about what his
pronouns are that they're prosecute
fouchy
she says I'd like to personally thank
Elon Musk for reminding America why
absolute power corrupts absolutely
what do you think this is it's all
corrupt power
he was able to buy Twitter for 44
billion and burn it
boom and so there's Rachel's response to
it oh
speaking of dillos and butt plugs
oh man I have another dildo for you uh
yeah you guys I heard that Lauren bobert
you talk about a [ __ ] butt plug
walking around
um she says uh
conservatives we need to be on offense
not defense so they need to be offended
is basically what you're saying and I
said You misspelled fascist for anyone
to believe that Lauren bobert is a
conservative is really [ __ ] dumb
Lauren you're a Christoph fascist you
are not a conservative if you were
conservative the base word of
conservative is to conserve not to turn
back you would want to keep the status
quo
not go back to something different you
[ __ ] idiot you're a fascist not a
conservative I mean I'm not I'm not that
[ __ ] I'm not that hip on
conservatives
and then conservatism is really [ __ ]
dumb to think that you can't do better
that's really stupid I don't care how
[ __ ] how much progress you've made
you can always do better
even if even if it's at the expense of
your own [ __ ] well-being the country
and the collective can be better dummy
but you're not a conservative you're a
fascist okay ain't it's straight Lauren
Lauren now let's see
what else is trending I know um we want
to watch this uh
Dave Chappelle video and he's still
trending at the very top I'll show you
I'll show you give you proof here
um here is the here's what's trending
right now Dave Chappelle is number one
with Elon Musk
number one I mean that's why I kind of
made it the [ __ ] thumbnail
um Elon gets booed and Elon Musk is
obsessed with wokism
he's so he's so awake on wokeism isn't
he he's awake and can see every part of
wokism that there is is really stupid
okay
um let's see what Tesla is trending
because no one's no one that Elon Musk
would attract to buy a Tesla is probably
going to buy a Tesla now Tesla's
probably [ __ ] uh let's see you think
you're gonna get a bunch of [ __ ]
trumped up white dudes to buy a bunch of
Teslas get the [ __ ] out of here
come on you really believe that [ __ ]
listen I I am number one in the rural
areas in this country there's not as
much [ __ ] infrastructure that we need
yet for EVS like that's the whole point
of the infrastructure bill that was one
of the main tenements of it is to get
rule internet and the the ability to
rule America to have EVS to to so we're
not so [ __ ] dependent on the gasoline
prices that they [ __ ] about every
[ __ ] day which again we could have
the big debate about
what leaves a larger carbon footprint
you know of producing electricity with
[ __ ] like coal mines and stuff or or
just pumping the [ __ ] our natural
resources out of the ground we can have
that debate that's debate but we can't
have it right now because we have people
like Elon Musk and Marjorie Taylor green
controlling their messaging so if you
think you're going to have a reasonable
debate with these people you're [ __ ]
you're an idiot
but
as far as EV goes the reason why there's
not a lot of EVS in rural areas because
there's not a lot of infrastructure for
electric vehicles there's just not and
really all around the country we're
getting there we'll get there but to
think to think that a [ __ ] isn't
gonna go buy a goddamn Ford F-150 that
looks like a [ __ ] pickup truck okay
it looks exactly like a pickup truck
that they want to drive this is [ __ ]
Common Sense
this is capitalism it's not that hard to
develop these ideas it really is not to
think that these [ __ ] brain dead
idiots who have their flags on the back
of their trucks their big tires and all
this [ __ ] you think they're gonna go buy
a Tesla a car that looks like a Tesla
you're a dumb [ __ ] Elon
and if you think you're gonna win the EV
war with Chevrolet and Ford putting out
what looks like a pickup truck okay it's
an EV but it looks like a pickup truck
okay
this really is really dumb [ __ ] but
anyways Tesla's [ __ ] and I I wouldn't
buy a [ __ ] Tesla I wouldn't have a
Tesla if you gave it to me
I wouldn't I wouldn't even take it to
[ __ ] destroy it [ __ ] no you keep that
some [ __ ] okay uh woke oh here we go
number 13 woke is trending oh oh great
woke yen maybe we'll get into that more
now let's see Bob Barker's trending
happy 99th birthday did you guys know
that Bob Barker's still [ __ ] alive
pop Barker is still alive
that's some crazy ass [ __ ]
motherfucker's 99 but he's still alive
congratulations Bob Barker and
congratulations to the world realizing
that
Bob Barker's still alive now get your
pets spayed and neutered by the way uh
while I'm thinking of it I don't know
why I'm thinking of it but you should
okay let's see what else
oh judge Cannon is trending did you hear
the news judge Cannon is irrelevant
that's right um the final the final
straw in the judge Cannon um Sangha is
done would judge Cannon releasing her
her what she thought was jurisdiction
over the documents case which she did
not have jurisdiction she states it in
her release of the of the [ __ ] orders
hmm so that's over when she's in the
trash bin of history now hopefully we
have other judges on the bench that are
willing to 86 this [ __ ] and de-platform
her from the bench and not let her have
any decisions at all from that Federal
judgeship but let's go back to number oh
looky here it's skipping around
Now Dave Chappelle and Elon Musk are
number two well we better get to this
before the trend goes away
I'm gonna show you this um I'm gonna
show you this video here
I have uh Dave Chappelle
um letting Elon Musk come on stage this
is a show that was in San Francisco
um and here is uh let's see here's a
larger this is a bigger video now I
haven't watched this one yet
let's go to the short one though let's
see where's the
just him getting booed that's all I want
I just want him getting booed
I don't want a two minute video yet God
damn it
see even Elon Musk doesn't know that I
just I don't want I just want to hear
him getting booed did he is he censoring
just the video of him getting booed it's
like a four second clip where the [ __ ]
is it are you [ __ ] kidding me
listen this is a strike to my freedom of
speech when I can't watch the four
second clip Elon Musk getting booed this
is [ __ ]
I he's censoring it
I'll show it to you here look
if you go up to the top of the trend
here to the top you know you got that
here let me show you
see how it says top okay let's go back
because I gotta go back into it all
right so it says top here right these
are the top tweets you can see Dave
Chappelle is here Elon Musk Stephen
gorfman which I don't know I guess that
maybe the person who broke this story
but you have all the all the top trends
here
um this this video here is 218. you see
here it's 218. that's not the one I want
I mean we're going to watch that one
we'll watch a longer one
um but I want to see the just the clip
see here's two five
um and this is from Steve Goffman that's
that's who that's why he's trending
because
but you see um
Brian Tyler Cohen has uh Steve goffman's
um
video embedded here and it's four
minutes and 48 seconds I'm not watching
that one
I mean it's way too [ __ ] long I just
want here's one that's 220. here's one
that's 448 it's all the same [ __ ]
video
because people are just embedding in or
quote tweeting it but this morning there
was a [ __ ] clip it was just four
seconds of Elon getting booed
it's just him getting booed
ah Dave Chappelle's like ah the rich man
in the world and the entire crowd's like
Boo [ __ ] you get off the stage
and it just it's not it's not there
anymore this is the I'm rich [ __ ]
um
uh
clip
oh that's so [ __ ] gross Dave so
[ __ ] gross Dave you [ __ ] it's
so gross
okay where is the [ __ ] clip where
he's get he [ __ ] censored did he
really uh somebody's check this chat
here
does anyone know did he [ __ ]
um okay uh someone's saying DM they got
it in the DM did he [ __ ] have it
censored
did he have it censored holy [ __ ]
yeah this that's that's that see that's
the [ __ ] that's the one
um
um from that's the four minute one from
Stephen Goffman
oh [ __ ] here it is here it is yeah yep
it did that [ __ ] that that
[ __ ] man I knew it I knew it
because I seen that clip this morning I
shared it now let's let's do this
um
here is
um right wing uh Republicans excuse me
Republicans against trumpism
um and they have it here says um wow
Elon Musk just suspended the Twitter
account that shared the video of him
being booed at the Dave Chappelle Show
in San Francisco
yes
he has the right to do it he absolutely
does again I was telling you this is his
freedom of speech now it shows truly who
he is
because this idea that he's somehow a
[ __ ] he wants everything to be
transparent everyone to see anything
that's [ __ ]
um yes right dude but don't pretend to
be a free speech abolitionist yes
absolutely excuse me absolutist he's not
a free speech absolutist he's a [ __ ]
snowflake really honestly and he's a
Nazi snowflake
he's a Nazi snowflake okay let's um so I
guess I guess we're gonna have to watch
the longer one you know what actually
let me see if I can still pull this up
I sent it
to my co-host and friend
um
that that's that's a longer one [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] I I told you the whole
time that these P it's all projection
all of it the whole [ __ ] [ __ ] in
caboodle
is projection I'm surprised he hasn't
why hasn't he banned me yet
come on Elon come on man look
this is this morning's announcement for
the show
Elon Musk is obsessed with wokeness I
even got his name maybe I should tag him
and I said Elon gets booed
is he in there
he got booed
why don't you ban me Elon
[ __ ] I'm I'm gonna broadcast this
[ __ ] video once I find it I know it
exists
I know it exists
all right well let's
let's go back because I'm running out of
time here
we're at uh we're 49 minutes into the
second hour
of me yapping on a Monday morning how do
you guys like that how do you like that
I like when Gabe Sanchez is here but how
do you like when it's just Tony day you
like that too I don't know I don't know
maybe okay let's see uh
here is the uh here's a video of it
here's the video of Elon getting booed
lentilism
Make some noise for the richest man in
the world now to be fair to Dave he
wasn't like clap cheer for he's like
make noise
poor Tony MJ says poor Tony
no no not poor me
hell I could talk for five hours
I could talk for five hours by myself I
talked beforehand this show and I talk
after the show and folks I talk to
my mom is one of them I don't know if
you guys know that I talk a lot to my
mom and she
oh she should have a show I'm not shiny
you think you like me you love my mom
now now I I'm Gabe Sanchez did the
thumbnail for us this morning and he
probably is listening I'm sure he's
listening but
um and if he is I'm sure I'm it maybe he
isn't he was not feeling well this
morning he had the cold sweats poor guy
had his coveted booster
um which everyone should go get theirs
too if you haven't already
um
but I I'm doing okay by myself I have I
I feel like I'm doing all right today
you know
I'm just saying
um so but here's Dave Chappelle again
let's get back to the show back to
enough distraction uh back to the show
um Dave Chappelle here
brings Elon Musk now remember they're in
San Francisco
so this is in the context of you know
Twitter headquarters which Elon Musk
um you know he's been looking in in the
woke closets for the woke T-shirts
because he's obsessed with wokeness he's
absolutely obsessed with being woke our
who are woke
you know Jesus he wants everyone to wake
up and stop being woke I don't know how
that works but anyways Dave Chappelle
does a show in San Francisco invites
Elon Musk on stage
and um he wants people to make noise
let's listen to the noise that they make
for Elon Musk the head Chief [ __ ] at
Twitter
oh my God
[Applause]
get him
[Music]
now again I I don't know if this is was
Dave Chappelle's um if this was the joke
that he would then he would pull Elon
Musk up on stage and and listen to
thousands of people boo him
um but um it really oh man whoosh whoosh
let's keep listening
okay
cheers
and of course Dave Chappelle has to
point out uh in front of Elon that
there's boost so maybe that was the joke
I don't know I wouldn't pull this
[ __ ] up on stage if you if he
paid me 44 billion dollars I'm not
[ __ ] you I wouldn't be in the same
room as this [ __ ] for 44 billion
hails to the no hails to the no that's
just me all right let's keep listening
here
Elon
today
[Music]
[Applause]
Dave says controversy and that may be
why Dave Chappelle is pulling him up
because he knows it's controversy he
knows it'll [ __ ] trendy knows it'll
get him attention it's the wrong type of
attention I think but whatever
man you know that's how it goes wait a
second uh
um I'm gonna I want to favorite that uh
comment I want to bring come back to
that not right now but I'll come back to
it here we go
okay see see what I mean see what I mean
Dave Chappelle making jokes here's the
thing about comedy and jokes and again
maybe I should pull up this to George
Carlin
um clip
on Larry King live where he's talking
about punching up and punching down
comedy comedians in general uh you know
call out call out
the rich and the powerful truth to power
not not the opposite and here Dave
Chappelle is punching
punching on people for getting fired now
it seems like elon's a Target so maybe
I'll give him that one but let's keep
listening
[Music]
boys
foreign
damn
[Music]
now you gotta remember the context of
this this cell phone that is recording
this sound is pretty far away from the
stage
um and it's in a crowd of people and
this microphone that's on the phone is
not really designed to pick up the crowd
noise that is happening so when you hear
the booze on that microphone the way
that you're hearing it in real life in
in real life if you're in that room it
would be much more prominent than what
that microphone is showing from this
this cell phone that this cell phone
microphone that we're getting it from
just just realize that
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
seeing there it is again there it is
again punching down there's Dave
Chappelle Rich [ __ ] comedian
standing on stage with what is supposed
to be the richest man in the world
punching down Dave you're punching down
let's keep listening
[Applause]
last minute
now I'm playing a [ __ ] blue
[Music]
[Music]
listen
damn again I know it's hard to hear on
this that there's no booze but Dave
Chappelle is pointing it out that there
is a very loud Boo in the room and the
reason why it's hard to hear is because
this microphone on this cell phone that
took this video is not designed to pick
up that sort of noise
um I do want to go back real quick
because I'm going to try to find this
George Garland uh clip but I want to
play the part where
um Elon Musk says the line from the Dave
Chappelle Show I'm rich [ __ ]
um it's really [ __ ] weird that Dave
Chappelle had him up on stage and
allowed him to say this just because of
where that line comes from in the Dave
Chappelle Show and that [ __ ] bit
because the reason why Elon Musk has so
much [ __ ] money is because he he is a
beneficiary of Apartheid
okay it's a apartheid little beneficiary
brand here's here's the moment I think
[Music]
oh that's really [ __ ] gross if you
know the context of that line I'm rich
[ __ ] and of course Elon can't say it
you know he can't he's such a worthless
piece of [ __ ] even Elon Musk can't get
the simple line I'm rich [ __ ]
like enunciate your [ __ ] words you
worthless piece of garbage
okay
um so let's see if we can find um while
I'm talking about this rich [ __ ] line
see if I can find this um video
from Larry King and and um George Carlin
you know what it might be online it
might be on my profile I don't know let
me see if I find it on YouTube
um
okay
so the context of the rich [ __ ] is that
in a bit on the Dave Chappelle show if
anyone remembers
um
this person buys a big huge box truck
full of cigarettes
and the reason why he buys a whole big
huge box truck full of cigarettes is
because he's rich [ __ ] but the reason
why he's rich in the bit
is because
black people got reparations so it
really is kind of [ __ ] gross
that
um I don't know maybe it's just me of
course you know I'm not actually
offended by it and the reason why
um
because
I I I'm I'm not black I'm white
I'm not supposed to be right
um okay here is let's see
that's the clip there yeah that's the
one
okay so I found this clip of George
Garland here and we're gonna play it
now let's see here it is put it in all
right
all right here's a clip from Carlin D
there we go on mute so this is the clip
from George Garland maybe this will
explain a little better than what I can
explain it listen I would defend to the
death his right to do everything he does
the thing that I find unusual and it's
you know it's not a criticism so much
but his targets are underdogged and
comedy traditionally has picked on
people in power people who abuse their
power uh women and gays and immigrants
are kind of to my way of thinking
underdogs and you know he ought to be
careful because he's Jewish and a lot of
the people who want to pick on these
kind of groups the Jews are on that list
a little further you've got women gays
Gypsies and suddenly you find Jews and
the answer yeah so uh you know I mean
obviously he should do what he wants and
uh why does he get away with it do you
think then well then you have never
laughed at jokes about that well he's
appealing I think he's appealing largely
I think his core audience our young
white males who are threatened by these
groups I think a lot of these guys
aren't sure they're manhood because
that's a problem when you're going in
through adolescence you know am I really
am my good idea I hope I'm not one of
them and the women who assert themselves
and are competent are a threat to these
men and so are immigrants in terms of
jobs and and uh and so that's why we as
an audience then will laugh you say we I
don't think I don't know but I think
you're attractive way I think that's
what what is at the core of that
experience that takes place in these
Arenas is a certain uh you know a
sharing of of uh anger and rage at these
at these targets and I'm sure Andrew
isn't that angry at them I'm sure he's
playing it as a comic
I would okay so there you have it with
George Garland um said it so perfectly
and I
um what is happening right now in our in
our country to a t now this was uh let's
see if I can figure out
I think this let's see
um of course this was on the Larry King
show and he was talking about Andrew
Dice Clay now Andrew Dice Clay at the
time was doing comedy about poor people
he was making poor people and immigrants
his Target of his comedy now again
Andrew Dice Clay for those who don't
know is an actual person and but the
comedian is is a character on stage
that's not actually Andrew Dice Clay
Andrew Dice Clay is doing a character
you know when he would do the nursery
rhymes
um one of the famous ones is
um twinkle twinkle little star how I
wonder what you are
um as I sit in this parking lot while I
eat my girlfriends yeah so that's and he
would oh oh yeah yeah oh oh that's
Andrew Dice Clay the character who does
the comedy on stage
um Andrew Dice Clay is a real person two
separate things
but what George Carlin is trying to say
there is that he will defend to the
death
Andrew Dice Clay's ability to say
whatever he wants
it's his freedom to say what he wants
but what he's saying is Andrew is doing
something that ultimately
puts this narrative out there that would
put him in danger
if the narrative would actually come to
fruition
and the narrative is is that white males
in this country
particularly ones that are really really
really touchy about their privilege
are the threat
and they're the threat to Dice Clay
they're the threat to Dave Chappelle
they're the threat to Elon Musk frankly
Kanye West Nick Fuente you pointed out
they're the [ __ ] they're the threat
because power is the threat just like
Rachel said absolute power
is the threat that's what they want
that's what they want to possess is
absolute power over you
and collectively the country
that's the whole point that's why comedy
in its history
has always aimed
at the powerful not at the marginalized
marginalized get enough [ __ ] Flack
the powerful are the ones that need to
that need to be on the receiving end
thank you for joining me today
Gabe Sanchez will be back with us
tomorrow I'm almost sure of it
our co-host and executive producer and
tomorrow's Tuesday so hopefully we'll
have Texas Texas Paul
um he should be here too it's Taco
Tuesday and Texas Paul Tuesday here on
the Tony Michaels podcast so don't
forget to tune in tomorrow noon Eastern
11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter
and twitch just like we do every single
weekday and we also simulcast from the
mind is touch Facebook page if you're
right there right now go over and follow
me on Facebook at the Tony Michaels I'm
almost at a thousand followers
also download every single episode on
Apple's Spotify Google and while Twitter
still exists go follow us over there at
Tony Michael's POD at the Tony Michaels
and at I am Gabe Sanchez go give Gabe
Sanchez a get well soon message until
tomorrow everyone
Surf's Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon